[Musique]
ils en ont marre de trinquer il n'arrive
plus à travailler trop de contraintes
horaires sanitaire pas assez de revenus
les restaurateurs lancé un cri d'alert
afin d'être entendus par le gouvernement
c'est le cas de gilbert fait baver
gérant d'une boîte de nuit depuis 25 ans
sa situation économique est de plus en
plus compliqué il a déjà été contraint
de réduire ses effectifs de travail est
que le gouvernement essayait de prendre
les meilleures mesures et se rend compte
au bout d'un moment qu'on ait pu écouter
que on nous prend un peu pour des ânes
je penche et où l'avancé pour montrer
que si ça continue comme ça là on avait
fait des pancartes nous on va vous rires
eh ben c'est pas loin d'être vrai malgré
le protocole sanitaire mis en place dans
ces établissements
ces professionnels se sentent
stigmatisés ils craignent que les jeunes
se rassemblent chez eux sans gestes
barrières et que le virus se propage
alexis didier indépendant est de plus en
plus inquiet pour lui et pour son métier
moi je me suis retrouvé avec aucune aide
zéro euro les factures à payer donc
compliqué c'est notre métier c'est une
autre métier de dj ainsi que
discothèques bars de nuit tout ça si tu
es notre métier
ils comptent manifester tous les
vendredis en attendant l'évolution de la
situation
d'autant que le département de la côte
d'or pourrait passer en vigilance
renforcé prochainement pour cette boîte
de nuit cela voudrait dire fermer dès
22h